Heyyyyy~ (so I'm being sarcastic)
It's me (gay sound) another video another day another video
You know, how all theses (getting deleted from my christian Minecraft server.) youtubers just go. "Oh GuYs I'Ve beEn MaKiNg VidEoS for ThrEe yeArS eveRy sInGle DAy"
boohoohoo eight years everysigle day
Every single day I don't take breaks
Is it even eight years? How long have I been doing this mother flippin nine years (omg really)
Let's begin meme review everyone's favorite show (claps) (this is a copyright show))
(Intro plays, the lyrics are already there on the screen)
I am honored to be Army General of the nine year old army, and I'm ready to host meme review
(it this reddit meme shows) "I am blue shirt kid!" Well, anyone, I think it's safe to say that anyone that gets a hundred thousand upvotes
Will automatically get to host meme review
(clap, CLAP)
Blue shirt kid put on your finest blue shirt because it is time to host meme review
Meme review with such host as Elon Musk and blue shirt kid (something) HI IF READING SUB TO PEWDS
I mean, I'm down. I'll be in touch with you blue shirt kid. Check out your DMs. The forgotten blue shirt kid
I am also on the side of PewDiePie because I don't like
T-series personally
So If I am in a bad mood. I can just watch him to feel better
(masturbation sound)
So wholesome and sweet. That was such a great video. I really enjoyed that.
Not the hero we deserve but the hero we need.
Captain Marzia everyone. Dayuumm
An actual superhero with not the flat ass. Am I right hahaha sexually object..
Now I would normally pick on people's appearance, but I don't like Brie Larson. (laughs)
Ask me anything I'll be answering it on my youtube channel
Alright blue shirt kid relax, you're getting meme review and that's final
Alright, where did you buy the blue shirt? That's what I want to know
I like how this guy just got like instant internet fame. Could you lend me the blue shirt?
Lawful good, neutral good, chaotic good. This is actually very
Accurate they did a good job getting all kinds of people. (laughs)
My god is my whole Reddit taken over by blue shirt kid?
Anime
Netflix adaptation
Incredible, what about the manga??? (a true otaku's question) Did you know that the bones in your fingers are shaped like penises?
Of course. Why else do you think I eat G fuel with my fingers? Cuz I'm gay. I'm gay son
I like dic-
If you can't figure out the name of a song just upload a video of you singing it to YouTube and they'll copyright it
Oh my god
Modern problems require modern solutions. I'm pretty sure this would work
Someone should try this. My final attempt at posting here, spent two months making it. I just want Pewds to see it
Now this guy went all out
It's another pewdiepie anime, Jesus Christ
Well, goddamn
ha
huah
Nice holy Sh--damn
What's that a devil may cry reference??
god damn , that's awesome
If we do like animation it should--I should voice acting Swedish
(Swedish)
Just- Just a thought
"pewds your sampling rate is set to,4:2:0".
I fail to see ANY PROBLEM with that (there are so many problems senpai)
That's the problem with the Video quality of your camera should be able to change it to ...anywhere... in the settings. Well goddamn
Bep bop
Ah,turns out: It's stuck on 4:2:0 listen, I'd really try my best Oh to fix the quality, but
This is pretty much IMAX
Cinema quality, so I think you guys should be satisfied
With the quality of this video.
No stop.
(laughs)
To celebrate International Women's Day,
tag the women creators who inspired you
Gloria Borger. That is so nice.
I really appreciate that Thank You rollick. That's gonna make her day. That's for sure. This is my second fan art this week
Why are you crying? It's awesome. Thank you very much
What is this an app? good 12 +...12 + to download the app??!! I do know that someone made a website
I think it's like pew news. Yeah, look pew news.org  It looks legit
About hosts. Look at all these hosts
Michelle Obama (true beauty)
Hahahaha
So they have all the topics we discussed, that's funny.
They even write it down as well?
Holy someone's spending work
Well done. He needs to host me review. Nobody: pewdiepie sub reddit:
Basically the new king do I even need to be here?
Every month you guys pick someone else that you prefer
I get it, Okay ?
Everyone : money is hard to get and should only be spent on necessary stuff. MrBeast :
What the freak is that even supposed to mean
I still don't understand where MrBeast get all his money from. Drug cartel ?
Please tell us MrBeast. I want to know...
Pewdiepie in you laugh you lose
(laughs)
Hey look
It's t-shirt kid again
When your kid asks you why there are twerking videos recommended to you
Okay, first of all because of the youtube algorithm
It's a good meme. That's a good meme right there
Felix laugh at our memes, but never up vote but
Sometimes I do, okay
I'm just not logged in, all right ? Cry more. shut up spider-man you're fat
I made a pewds toy with..
Oh my god. Oh my- hahah
What I fixed what
chair launching, WHOA
AH!! HAHAHA
That's incredible guys check out lost in the fold I link in the description only 135 subscribers
I paused the PewDiePie vid while my YouTube was lagging
Big mistake. Oh my god. HE'S TAKING OVER ME
"Hey bros on May 31st. We should celebrate Brad's birthday for his hard work editing pewd's videos"
Now hold on just a second here. This is a trap
I've known Brad for I don't know how many years now
and every year I try and figure out when his birthday is because he
will never say it I know more or less the timeframe
because his mom just appears out of nowhere and Brad just goes
Yeah, my mom is here. Sorry and I'm just like why is your mom here? Hmm. Oh, it's birthday time
But Brad will not tell anyone when it's his birthday. How did you figure this out?
It's this posted by secret brad, is this a trap ?
How did this random reddit person know brad's day.
"Nice try, Brad. Now return to the dungeon from whence Pewds keeps you."
That's right Brad. Nice try.
Pewd's five minutes before Pew News
Gloria Borger
Ah no? oh my god me telling my friend why my meme with 1.8 thousand up votes didn't get into LWIAY?
Okay, first of all, because of BRAD
Petition for blue shirt kid to become CEO of the YouTube
Jesus, correct?
Oh my god, when your friends ask you why you only have four subscribers?
Okay, first of all because of the YouTube algorithm
Kids are dumb and changed my mind. I changed my Mind
(laughs)
(INHALE)
Oh my god
Met Pewds in Iceland, used his camera
(laughs) To take a photo
You friking b**ch
HOW DARE YOU
That is not my camera
Look the eyes
"Then too, your face seems to have better quality"
Yeah what the hell ??
"He lives in 240p" Goddammit
This is Bullying!!
When your parents ask you why there's hentai on your recommended?
Okay, first of all because of the YouTube algorithm.
I just noticed it's been Lasagna all along
That's right. Everyone. Oh my gosh. I didn't see the G-FUEL I was like, oh, yeah
It's another one of these Oh G-FUEL 10/10. Very nice.
Why you push the ad just drink G fuel?
Pathetic for legal disclaimer. Please do drink the G fuel and don't inhale it or any other ways to eat it
Thank you.
Now I will continue my habits
Pewds: I'm 1.8 meters
Also Pewds:
BULLYING
"You were the chosen one. You were supposed to destroy T-Series not copystrike us!"
"Dr. Phil: To the Ranch" Okay, let's get this done Sony TV
Now it has been three days and all my Dr. Phil videos are still claimed except the ones I privated.
Thank God. Now I expect Sony TV to REMOVE THESE CLAIMS IMMEDIATELY
Or else I'm gonna drop a diss track on you, Sony
You've seen what happened to T's series their company is never going to recover.
You don't want to make this enemy sony/atv
Remove the (hit) claims (hit) immediately
Damn to new milestones. We hit 89 million subscribers and b**** lasagna It's my most viewed video.
Inc- Incredible, I remember I have to skip an upload to work on beach lasagna am like oh god I missed one upload
This is terrible. I think it paid off
(laughs)
I'm so proud. I can't believe this channel is still peaking after nine years. It's crazy
Thank you guys so much for all the support
It genuinely means so much to me
Smash like and I see you guys.
In the by- bye
Tuber simulator. It's now so relevant that it's got a brand new mini game
Craniac
drop the crane and get fresh items only available in the washing machine like game and you say there's more of course there is
new knowledge perks new quests and new pixelings and legs
guys
legs